nevada's top elected leaders and  national democrats plan on bypassing the  nevada democratic party  there has been tension within the party  since members of the democratic  socialists of america  or dsa took all the top leadership spots  in the  nv dems now the top elected democrats  have set up a shadow party to run their  2022 campaigns  called nevada democratic victory  normally running campaigns is the job of  the state party the new group  has been endorsed by the governor both  senators and leaders in the legislature  fundraising money from national  democratic organizations will now go  through the washoe county democrats